good day everyone and welcome I'm Jack Van
Horn from the University of Virginia and I'm
very proud to welcome you to this edition of
our 2022-2023 foundations of biomedical data
science seminar Series this lecture series is
supported by uva's integrated translational
Health Institute of Virginia the UVA brain
Institute the College of Arts and Sciences
the school of data science and through grants
from the National Institutes of General Medical
Sciences since 2016 the foundations of biomedical
data science seminar Series has focused on the
use of data science methodologies artificial
intelligence deep learning and statistical
modeling as they pertain to different themes in
the biomedical and Health Sciences this year's
theme is data science and the public health
consequences of the covid-19 pandemic where we
will enjoy presentations on Fridays from leading
thinkers about the issues promised opportunities
and hurdles associated with understanding the
secondary health effects of covet 19. these
include but do are not limited to delayed Health
checkups treatments mental health concerns drug
abuse increased obesity and the long lingering
effects associated with the SARS covid-19 virus
indeed our 2022-2023 application cycle is now
open and we welcome Junior faculty members who
are working in areas such as infectious diseases
epidemiology clinical medicine population Health
Data science machine learning AI statistics and
other relevant domains to consider applying we
believe that this will be an exciting opportunity
and engaging program where characterizing the
secondary effects of covid-19 necessitates
unique multi-disciplinary approaches um to
understanding these secondary health consequences
participants selected for our biomedical
data science Innovation lab will Leverage The
presentations you're just about to hear as well
as vital material for our upcoming culminating
in-person Grant project development Workshop to
be held at the lodge at St Edwards Park in Seattle
Washington in June 2023. today I am delighted to
welcome our speaker Professor Shane G Henderson
from Cornell University Dr Henderson holds
uh the Charles W Lake Junior chair in productivity
in the school of operations research and
information engineering at Cornell University he
earned his bachelor's degree in mathematics from
the University of Auckland in 1992 his master's
degree in statistics from Stanford where he
also received his PhD in operations research in
1997. his research interests include discrete
event stimuli simulation simulation optimization
emergency service planning and transportation he's
the editor-in-chief of the Open Access Journal
stochastic systems he is an informs fellow and a
co-recipient of the informs Wagner prize for his
work on bike sharing programs so in continuing
with our biomedical data science Innovation or
excuse me biomedical data science seminar series
theme Shane's lecture today is entitled keeping
campus open designing mitigation strategies with
biased data unlike most universities Cornell was
very um adventurous in reopening its Ithaca campus
for in-person instruction in the fall of 2020
during the covet period and did so safely through
the use of pooled testing their decision to do so
and many others were Guided by the mathematical
modeling group and Shane will discuss some of the
questions they explored the models they built and
data that informed their models and how they dealt
with several interesting challenges Cornell's
work here under the direction of Shane and his
colleagues helped him motivate um further work
in exploiting biased data in epidemiological
models as always we are streaming this lecture
live and for recording via YouTube and if you're
watching on YouTube thank you for joining us also
our specially selected 2022-2023 biomedical data
science Innovation lab participants and alumni are
encouraged to submit any questions they may
have for Shane in the chat feature of their
Zoom sessions all synthesize these and ask those
questions on your behalf in the last 10 minutes
or so of the lecture and with that welcome Shane
we are so much looking forward to your lecture
you're mutaging yes I am indeed thank you
Jack it's great to be here uh and I really
appreciate the opportunity to to tell you
a little bit about our experience so yeah I
want to tell you about the Cornell experience
which is not unique but it's close to Unique
um I want to introduce a few characters here first
so Peter Frazier the person on the left he was the
ringleader so he was he was the guy who really
brought this all together he's a faculty member
in this department with me uh David schmoy
is beside him is another faculty member in
the department who led another Direction in
this work and I'll explain what what he was
doing there and then we had this sort of large
cast of characters to the right it's a mix of
PhD Masters and undergraduate students and
then there'll be some more people with the
obligatory Zoom window shut a little bit later
in the talk but these were the main characters
so what we were doing was trying to ensure that
we could keep the Cornell campus open uh in by
hook or by crook but using some sort of Philly
a powerful methods to keep things under control
but our story was not uniformly positive and I
want to bring out those those aspects as well
so uh the key themes that we're going to bring out
that we're going to see in this talk uh number one
Cornell reopened safely in the fall of 2020 so
as you'll recall that was the the sort of the
the semester immediately after The Madness of
March April May uh period Cornell has remained
safe uh to to the present time but we've had
our share of uh sort of interesting moments
uh the the word modeling here refers to
mathematical modeling so uh lots of mathematical
epidemiology in here uh but our group we're not
really epidemiologists uh directly but we do have
a lot of experience with operations so you heard
about the bike sharing work earlier that uh is
certainly doesn't look anything like this work but
the mathematical principles are kind of similar
so we looked at things like uh testing the testing
frequencies how often we actually test individuals
to try to keep people safe we looked at classroom
safety is is it safe to bring people into the
classroom if they're socially distanced wearing
masks we looked at should the university require
boosters you know a whole bunch of different
questions and it was a incredible experience
where we were directly linked with the leadership
of the University and the reason this was possible
was that we have science driven leaders here
at Cornell uh president Martha Pollock is a
computer scientist our uh Provost Mike kotlikoff
is something that I cannot pronounce but it's a
science kind of position anyway um so then we
have uh many other aspects to this work that
made this work so huge efforts in communication
you'll see a couple of examples of that later
on but a big one for example was that Peter
the person I mentioned to you first who was
our leader was meeting daily with the other
leaders of the University Martha Mike and and
others daily through that fall 2020 semester to
try to make sure that things were going okay and
so that that sort of gives you an idea of the the
penetration to the leadership of the University
our modeling group had an appreciation for and
explicitly modeled things that we didn't know and
this will be a theme that we'll bring out later
and I think it's important to recognize both the
strengths and the limitations of the data that we
had available I will try to highlight that as well
a key point is that we did the analysis when it
was needed and that meant that we didn't do the
perfect analysis we did something that enabled
a decision to be well informed and that meant
sometimes that we couldn't do the analysis we
really wanted just because of time pressure
and then a final theme is that in in doing all
of this we actually used a range of different
decision models not just one and the models were
sort of complementary to one another that theme
won't come out too uh explicitly in this talk but
it's it's certainly underlay much of what we did
so I want to uh take you back to this period
so March 2020 through to December 2020 in this
first part of this conversation and the picture
you're seeing here is of the lovely Ithaca Campus
of Cornell so that we also have other campuses
there's Cornell Tech in New York City but this
is the one in Upstate New York so uh the question
we were facing back in June of 2020 actually a bit
earlier than that was should we ask students
to return in the fall just like all other
universities were considering and this was done in
the context of some rather disturbing case counts
uh you're seeing a sort of a blurry image here I
apologize for the quality of something like what
we were seeing in case Council written around
that time and this was the context in which we
were trying to make this decision and there
were two different perspectives on this left
and right of this uh panel respectively on the
left there was this perspective that bringing
students back was dangerous they they would be
irresponsible they would have parties like you
see in this upper left and that would lead
to a number of people um being infected when
they would not otherwise have been and so it was
perceived as a dangerous consideration but trade
that with the right hand side perspective
which is that when people are purely online
um they are isolated and that can lead to all
kinds of problems educational problems mental
health problems and so on but also for a town like
Ithaca which is quite small there are a number
of Staff would have lost their jobs because they
would we would they would not have been supporting
students who were there alive so these are
serious issues uh it's lives it's also livelihoods
so uh the issue here that we wanted to exploit
was testing and certainly testing was a hot hot
button issue back then the thing that made
us uh have hope was that we were fortunate
in that we have a Veterinary uh hospital here
on campus and our lucky break we have a PCR lab
for testing livestock and it was believed
that we would be able over the summer to
modify that lab to enable it to do PCR testing
for our students and staff faculty community
so like many places we started to explore poured
testing so just as a quick recap you take a bunch
of swabs from individuals into their individual
tubes but then what you do is you take a bit of
the fluid from each of those first those five
cubes do one test to see if virus is present in
the pooled sample if the test comes back negative
we conclude perhaps incorrectly but we conclude
that all five samples are negative if it comes
back positive then we'll test the original tubes
individually to try to hunt for the individuals
that are positive so we use pool testing with
pools of size five in the lab and with this kind
of two-stage approach so the strategy that was
proposed back in April of 2020 was should we test
all well we'll test all students upon arrival to
the campus and then every on a regular basis
after that we will contact Trace isolate the
positives we will use aggressive quarantining and
what we call adaptive testing adaptive testing is
where let's say that somebody tests positive on
the hockey team then rather than wait for that
person to identify the other members of the hockey
team as being potential contacts we would just
quarantine the entire hockey team until they could
be tested and determined positive or negative
and then we of like every other place we're
considering masks and social distancing but we
also and this was David schmoise the second person
I highlighted uh contribution or key contribution
was we rebuilt our class schedule so I'll tell
you a bit about that as well the big question
was can this work will we be able to bring people
back safely so we used a pretty standard approach
so we built a sort of a simulation model this is
a standard seir kind of model with a few extra
compartments um so I won't go through the details
here I'm sure you've seen these things many times
but basically just tracking People's State in
the population and we included some additional
information which would be standard information
for these as well I just want to highlight the
groups so we had students who were we we separated
the population into groups and uh an important
group there was undergraduates who were in high
density housing staff and faculty with frequent
student contact and there were other groups as
well but I'll just sort of mention those for now
and then we just use this model as a um as a
predictor and you can see the sort of standard
curves that you tend to see from these seir models
one thing you'll notice is that these curves are
a little bit Wiggly that's because we have a
stochastic simulation model our model is not
a differential equation model at least this one
is not what we've built here is a is is actually
modeling uh the randomness in in the sort of daily
fluctuations we felt that was important because
the number of infections we were aiming for was
quite small and when the number of infections
is small those differential equation models
are not as helpful as they might otherwise be
so the key issue of course was populating
this model with parameters that we actually
believed and so what are those parameters that
things like the probability that someone gets
infected when they have a close contact it's the
probability of having severe disease given that
you've been infected and all of these parameters
are stratified by age groups because as you can
imagine or as you know the campus population has
a heavy block of these young adults who are the
students but then also has a distributed
population through the staff and faculty
so we were hunting for data in those early days so
imagine it's April or May of 2020 we were trying
to figure out what these parameters ought to be
so you probably remember the Diamond Princess
cruise ship and there was early data coming out
of uh Wuhan uh Washington State and also Italy
so we would uh what we did is we we looked at
those we looked at all other kinds of sources
it's certainly the CDC website but then what we
had to do was try to sort of reconcile all of
these conflicting data sources to try to predict
what kind of disease spread parameters and so
forth we would we would be experiencing so we used
various fitting methods to to try to come up with
numbers that made sense and for example we we had
some conflicting data from Washington State and
from some of these cruise ships and what we did
was we said well let's find the most likely value
of these parameters but subject to constraints
on things that we believe are true such as the
probability of severe disease-given infection is
increasing in age right so that given that you've
been infected you're probably of severe infection
should be increasing as you get older and so we
would we would use those kinds of constraints to
um if in effect sort of improve the ability of the
data to inform these models all of the data was
biased that's for sure because the data came from
different uh different um scenarios or different
worlds from from the campus so uncertainty
quantification in our world was essential and what
I mean by uncertainty quantification is not pick
the most likely value of these parameters and
then run with that it was there are a range of
these input parameters that could be important
let's make sure that we've got some coverage of
that uncertainty that we're representing our
uncertainty in some reasonable way but after
all of that the simulation model suggested to us
that testing could really have tremendous impact
so uh in this picture what you're seeing on the
horizontal axis is a prediction of the percentage
of the of the campus population that would be
infected over the course of an entire semester
and on the vertical axis you're just seeing
how often that happens in our simulations
so for the Cornell Ithaca campus if we do
not do surveillance testing our models were
predicting that we would see something like 60
of the population infected over the course of
the semester and the reason it's sort of bunched
around 60 is because you're reaching some kind of
herd immunity up at that level uh but if we were
to do the surveillance testing with a frequency of
once every five days which is not that convenient
but um in any case suppose that with a frequency
then you would see this bunching down near zero
so still positive but but down near zero and it
was plots like this that immediately gave us
confidence that we were onto something here
so the key thing though was then well how
can we make this as effective as possible
given the capacities that we have for testing
so I want to show you a plot and on this plot
you can see daily tests on the horizontal axis
and infections on the vertical so I'm going to
take a particular method for testing so here the
letter B corresponding to this point means that
we're going to test undergraduates who are in
high density housing twice a week we will test
off-campus stuff once a month and everyone
else once a week so that's one strategy one
could follow there are other strategies but if we
follow that strategy we would need something like
4 000 tests a day and we would need uh sorry
we would experience we predict something on
the order of 2000 infections over the course of
the semester so that's the prediction for one
testing regime and we looked at a whole bunch
and so we generated a plot that looks like this
uh so uh each of these uh letters here again
corresponds to a different testing regime and
the one we selected is this one that's sort of
highlighted here so one thing that was critical
uh or sorry one thing I want to emphasize
before the administration saw this plot they
were planning on 4500 tests a day as being the
maximum capacity they could support after seeing
this plot they bumped that up to 7 500. so this
plot had an enormous impact on the University's
uh intended strategy for dealing with testing
and the reason that they wanted to go to the
higher level and perhaps put on the extra shifts
that are needed for that was that they could see
that this was providing some level of robustness
by moving to 7 500 tests a day we could be we
were sort of a long ways away from this kind of
scary uh jump here so we worried endlessly about
uncertainty so in this plot you're seeing um uh
the average number of contacts per person per day
that's uh sort of just um an important measure
in all of these these models and and the nominal
value the value that we felt was sort of most
likely for this parameter was something somewhere
around about eight slightly over eight so
about here because that's a log log plot
um that would lead uh in our sort of uh sort of
middle or sort of expected scenario to a certain
percentage of the population being infected
which here looks like it's about four so if
if if the truth is eight contacts per day we'll
see about four percent of the population infected
but this quickly changes as that average number
of contacts per day increases or decreases so we
had many plots like this exploring the potential
for problems uh and this plot was another one that
was very influential on the administration so on
the horizontal axis I'm showing you the expected
number of contacts per day we can't control
that that is something that we just have to
live with and we don't know where it's going
to fall on this axis on the vertical axis I'm
plotting the daily percentage of the population
that we test and that's something we can control
so we have something we can control on the
vertical but something we cannot on the horizontal
and what we're what you're seeing in this plot
this is a contour plot that shows the expected
number of infections you would see through
combinations of these two parameters so if we
have 15 contacts per day a very high number but
we're testing a third of the population per day
then we would expect to see something like
1500 infections and you can see a kind of a
cliff here in this Contour plot this region here
is really scary in any case the nominal value for
this expected number of contacts per day was
eight but we had some uncertainty about where
that was going to fall if we test once every five
days then we expect to see something like uh uh
what is this about 1500 infections but notice
how close we are to this Cliff if that number
of contacts is slightly higher we could be in
serious trouble so by elevating the number of
tests per person the frequency of testing
we can we can move up on this curve reduce
the number of expected infections but also move
ourselves away from this Cliff so that was vital
and then this uh con the conclusion one
obtains from this plot is the the big one
this is the the one that really swayed the
administration this was the the sort of Crux
so what are we seeing in this plot I want you
to notice that you've got residential Cornell
infections listed down here so that says if we
hold a regular residential semester how many
infections might we see in a particular situation
and then on the vertical axis I'm showing you a
different uh prediction this is virtual coronal
infections that means if we go online only
so no in-person classes at all then how many
infections might we see in our in our population
each dot in here is a prediction from the
simulation under a plausible set of input
parameters so remember all those parameters
we didn't know what they were each dot here
corresponds to a plausible value for those
parameters and then what you're seeing is this
cluster of dots up here so what's going on like
pick this dot here just this one so what we're
assuming here or what sorry what we're predicting
is that if the true parameters are corresponding
to this dot then we would probably see whatever
this number is down here uh residential Cornell
infections um in a residential semester but if
we were instead with the same parameters running
a virtual semester then we would see something
like whatever this is maybe 600 or something
um so uh each of these dots then corresponds
to a particular possibility of the world and
you notice that all of the dots pretty much are
above the line so that's telling us that we will
typically expect to see many more infections
if we go virtual than if we go residential
there are a few places where the dots fall below
the line down here but in those situations the
number of infections is quite modest and so
there we are not focused on those from risk
what we care about is this big area up here now
in some scenarios it's bad no matter what you do
so these kinds of scenarios up here this is just
the situation is just too dire you can't keep up
so a plot like this was incredibly important
because it's sort of telling you that basically
you should go residential and that sounds a
little bit weird right like you're bringing
people back for in-person semester and you're
gonna uh be in better shape that way well the
reason this was this was good was that uh when
people come back for a residential semester
we can enforce a behavioral compact which
says you will be tested on a regular basis
you come back to the campus you sign up for
residential you will subscribe to this but
for the virtual uh semester there's no
such mandate we can impose not legally
and we knew from surveys that we were going
to get many people coming back to the campus
anyway that already paid for their lease and
so they the students would want to come back
so in that virtual semester we have a large campus
population who are sort of in the general area
but they're not getting tested frequently and
therefore if there is infection it's going to
spread through that population very quickly
so these dots all correspond to infections
sort of getting out of control and getting an
epidemic amongst that um that on-campus Community
um so that was the key and and when
Martha Pollock our president saw this uh
um she didn't see this exact plot
but when she saw this conclusion
um the decision was very clear for her she wanted
to minimize harm and the right way to do that is
to have the residential semester so uh she and
Mike kotlikov wrote an article for the Wall Street
Journal which was explaining the the planning
here and uh so this article was put out there to
to basically win hearts and minds and explain what
the decision was you'll notice here that there's a
a little phrase here it says
surprisingly the work that we've done
um you know sort of explains what's going on so
uh again you're seeing this theme of communication
uh there was more communication so Peter
uh appeared before the faculty Senate uh he
appeared on ABC News along with the leaders in the
University uh here's Peter again I guess on The
Daily uh newspaper we were also interacting with
local politicians to to help make decisions for
the local uh sort of the broader Community because
Cornell is a in an Upstate area you're not making
decisions in isolation you have to think about the
the surrounding Community as well but basically
what was safer for Cornell was also safer for
the community so that was the analysis that was
leading up to the big decisions in the summer uh
to to reopen but there was a little bit more to
the story I'm just going to highlight some of that
and then highlight what happened when we when we
reopened so uh the the key question here was well
we're going to go residential but uh we also don't
want people just sitting in their dorm rooms
can we run classes in some sort of safe manner
and it was clear that the the very big classes you
know imagine psych 101 or something or calculus
those classes had to go online only because
they were just too big that we couldn't put
them anywhere but for the smaller classes what we
could do is we could use the large rooms on campus
and spread those students out in those classrooms
so we we planned that so we would have them six
feet apart and we would um uh sort of rotate
them through eligibility for attending in-person
classes so I'll skip this about pod models so
um the the natural thing that you can see is
that the classroom capacity is going to be a small
fraction of what you can normally use so we have
to realign and recreate this class schedule so
David schmoyes and his team uh this gang rebuilt
that uh classroom schedule over the the summer of
2020. and there was a lot to that story so uh they
had many many hair racing moments I'm just going
to sort of skip through some of this but basically
it was six weeks from when they started to do that
to when they had a had a schedule the the issue
that they were really frustrated with was that
they had to integrate with the existing computer
systems on campus and some of those computer
systems are pretty old so there were some real
challenges there uh one key thing that I want to
highlight here is they had they had different sub
teams that were building two different ways to
do the scheduling they had the method that they
really wanted which is this thing they're calling
the decomposition approach but they had a separate
approach which was just based on some sort of
reasonable heuristics so that if the decomposition
approach were to fail they would have this
heuristic to fall back upon and um so the the
biggest hurdle for them was was dealing with the
computer systems and they came down to the wire
and David is fond of telling us the story of when
Mike kotlikoff our Provost fixed him with a Steely
uh stare and said you will have a schedule for
us by tomorrow won't you David and David said yes
sir and then he had to go and figure out how to do
it but they got it they got it so it worked and I
want to just uh show you uh one statistic for that
so here you're seeing a plot of student enrollment
on the horizontal axis and total infections
over the the Academic Year not just the fall
um for a bunch of different universities so each
dot here corresponds to a different University
and then the color coding tells you uh what their
status was so the thing you notice is that Cornell
is sitting here it's a campus of about 21 22 000.
uh students the outcomes we had with our hybrid
year were quite similar to Harvard's which was
fully online um and Harvard um uh was sorry so
Harvard was fully online so these are fairly
similar um you notice that Chicago down here
um with a with a smaller enrollment header
similar number of infections but basically
the experience here was similar um and then
these these online only uh colleges uh head
um you know maybe not such a good experience
yeah sorry Stanford did pretty well but uh but
they were online only MIT and Yale had had more
concerns now to be fair some of these universities
are more um Urban campuses where there's a lot of
interaction with the surrounding community and we
had less of that so we were able to get away with
that I think but essentially we had a good year
some places that were facing the same decision and
went with online only had the opposite experience
so Michigan State University this is near Lansing
in Michigan uh they they are sort of similar in
that it's a sort of a more rural kind of area
they went online only and they had this big
surge of cases at the start of the semester and so
they they were forced to uh to try to get people
away from the town so this was the thing we were
worried about so we did not experience that surge
so there were hiccups here all the way through uh
students um were we discovered that students had
new quarantine rules just a few days before
uh the students were due to arrive so these
were imposed by New York State um also from New
York state from Governor Cuomo all of a sudden
there was a new rule about a week and a half to
two weeks before the semester began saying if
an educational institution has a hundred cases
or more in two weeks they must go online only
and what annoyed us was that this number 100 was
a constant threshold it didn't matter the size of
the institution so Cornell was subject to the
same cat as Colombia as NYU as all these other
universities including some very small ones so
that was annoying but it turns out we were okay
with that uh one thing that happened that was a
bit of a scare was after November 3rd of 2020 and
that's a significant date um from the political
side we had an outbreak but you know what are
you going to do and then also uh you know we had
our own sort of problems as well I'm sure you did
too uh turns out mbas and St Patrick's Day uh not
not great so each semester had new problems new
challenges so the spring of 2021 you may recall
the UK variant was uh on the on the horizon we
were concerned about that showing in showing up
and that would mean that the estimates that we had
for infection rates and so forth for the fall just
gone were too low so we had to deal with that uh
we weren't sure what fraction of the the student
body would be vaccinated and and then as the
summer of 2021 sort of progressed we were learning
more about Delta and embracing ourselves for that
and changing our interventions but I want to now
move to a really tumultuous period and just sort
of really highlight the the impact of real-time
data because up till now what I've shown you is
the impact of modeling uh and now what I want to
say is or what I want to highlight is is yes there
was modeling but there was also just looking
at the data and looking at it in creative ways
so this was our experience throughout the period
that we've talked about till now so in the fall
of 2020 we had some scary moments this was when
the semester was beginning and what happened was
our testing had not yet begun and there were a
student's partying not many but some and that
created this kind of surge in cases here then
we had a quiet fall semester which was great
um until November the 3rd um here and then
uh quiet period through uh but then we had
um problems with parties and spring break
and um the Saint Patrick's Day and so on
in this period but we got through
uh not much happening in the summer
and then when people came back and Delta was
present as well um most we had a vaccination
requirement everybody was vaccinated
or basically everybody was vaccinated
um but you can see this this huge Spike so this
was Delta and uh we weren't sure we were going to
get on top of it but we did manage to get on top
of it and then control the rest of the semester
but what I want to show you now is what happens
subsequent to what you're seeing in this plot
so the Story begins on uh Wednesday November 24th
the day before Thanksgiving so we expected a spike
in cases as students return from their homes
bringing covert back with them we'd seen that
many times before and on that day Omicron was was
uncovered and so became something that that could
potentially be concerning on Thanksgiving
it was classified as a variant of concern
and on that day Gary karetsky this is this
person you see up here Gary was what is one of
the leaders of the campus he sent an email to the
Provost and Peter saying hmm should we be worried
about this um so uh we all had our Thanksgiving
turkey or whatever and then we gave ourselves
a day off after that and then on November the
27th we started thinking well we better plan for
Omicron it's probably going to be here in the
spring we're going to have to be alert to that
so we're going to use the remaining time in the
semester to Think Through how we can address that
so we realized that the testing schedules that
we were using even with the fully vaccinated
population we're not going to be enough that
was uh that came out from our modeling pretty
quickly so we needed a new strategy so um
a little bit later we had gone through that
period after the Thanksgiving period where
we thought we had controlled the cases and
um and sort of handled the surge it was actually
not much of a search there so um we say okay there
was a bit of a surge but it's okay it's not too
bad and that's just the Thanksgiving break and
people having parties when they get back and end
of classes it'll be okay so on December 8th things
took a turn for the worse and we discovered that
there had been this big we call them guardless
big parties to celebrate the end of classes and
we started looking at these numbers with some
trepidation the numbers seem to be increasing
classes had stopped and we were in study week
um the the case counts remained elevated on
December 9th and we were worried and then we got
really worried because it just wasn't showing any
sign of ticking back down despite the the testing
that we were doing so we started to question
whether this is Omicron and on Saturday it was uh
really scary so I was planning an exam in my class
a big class um the following day and I was hearing
from students quite frequently that they had
tested positive and were isolating and would need
some sort of accommodation and it got to the point
where I thought this is beyond what I can handle
uh in any kind of reasonable way so I canceled my
class uh my exam and came up with some other plan
uh but this was really just getting moving and um
on that day we said to the administration maybe
this is Omicron right like like we're seeing
huge case counts and we're not controlling it
it's different from what we've seen in the past
and on that day we had to make a big decisions
or we wanted to we needed to explore a
decision so the lab had been checking
um throughout uh for testing you know just testing
students but they weren't necessarily just testing
for Omicron they didn't have the time to do the
additional work that was needed to to determine
whether a positive case was Omicron or Delta and
so we had seen a couple of Omicron samples very
early in December but we the the thinking was that
we had controlled for that it had it it was okay
but because the lab was just so overwhelmed with
these case counts you know here 200 in one day
they were not able to do this additional testing
that was needed to look for Omicron markers
so the question was should the lab pause its
testing of uh cases in general because it takes
time to do this to look for Omicron in the the
positive samples that would allow us to change the
way that the university is operating because we
would then have the clear sense that it's Omicron
but it would it would slow down um finding
infectious people and isolating them so we
could that could actually that decision to look
for Omicron could lead to more cases overall so
there was some disagreement amongst the leadership
group uh about whether Omicron had arrived
on the I believe it was the next day um so uh
we showed the administration this plot so on the
horizontal axis is time and on the vertical axis
cases the gray area here is the people that have
been identified in contact tracing and the red
region here is the fraction of those uh potential
contacts uh the fraction of those contacts sorry
who tested positive and what you see is this kind
of giant shading of red here and if you look
at the fraction of the gray that's covered by
red this is a very scary area because it's showing
that a very large fraction of the contact tracing
individuals are testing positive so we're seeing
a much larger fraction of people testing positive
and that uh was a very strong signal it seems to
drop a little bit later but that's just because
certain numbers hadn't been reported by the date
that we obtained this data so we took this data
to the administration and um yes uh we we say it's
Omicron um uh I guess I'm getting a little ahead
of myself but but uh Peter Frazier and I went to a
conference that we typically go to um that evening
Peter had a call with the Provost and other
leaders you know should we be talk uh pausing
that lab given the information we're seeing in
this plot you see in the top left and the decision
came from Mike yes we we need to do that so on
Monday December 13th they tested many of the uh
samples and what they found was that yes there
was sgn Dropout in a large very large fraction
basically overwhelming now that's not proof that
it's Omicron but it's pretty strong evidence and
that was enough to say yes we need to change the
the strategy of the University so on December
14th uh we went uh we had to go we were forced
to go to this online only kind of uh strategy
for the exams that were left um we you know we
put in a whole bunch of other uh restrictions
um and uh then yes sure enough we showed up on CNN
uh because this was the first real instance the
first uh outbreak that we had seen in the U.S uh
Peter tried to to live under his normal life give
us give his conference talk and then immediately
after that he started talking to reporters um I
always had this sort of delightful position that
I was embedded deeply within the modeling team
but Peter was the figurehead and so Peter was the
the guy that sort of carried the the bulk of this
so what happened overall well this is the
amazing thing Omicron arrived on campus four
days after it was it was uh discovered four
days and we were hoping for spring semester
but it was just shortly after this thing was
discovered there's no way our testing regimes
were able to keep up with its transmissivity
and so we had a large number of infections 2
800. almost entirely actually undergraduates
but there were some graduate students as well
no hospitalizations so uh consistent with
other things you will have heard about Omicron
and the big thing that I want to
highlight is that this focus on
real-time data really did change the way
that Cornell responded to the situation
so then we had to sort of say well now that
we've sort of somehow managed to hobble
through to the finish line on the fall semester
what do we do next so our data suggested from
contact tracing data that Omicron was three
to five times more transmissible than Delta
um so students are kind of done with them asking
you know they were kind of fed up at that point
we all were right and so we just concluded that
very large student infection counts were just
going to be part of the deal for the spring and
so we had models that that we're looking at if
we test once a week twice a week and so on and
you see that these curves are bending down but
the infection counts are very large here so we
were concerned that there wasn't much we could do
so the good news is that the as as we've seen the
serious health effects are unlikely most of the
cases are mild but I do recognize that this group
is is sort of expert in Long covered it's an area
I know nothing about so that was something
that we did not factor into our calculations
so another thing that we had seen and this
I also want to highlight infected students
almost never infect uh non-student
employees that staff and faculty
um so um we didn't see that kind of transmission
moving uh into the staff and faculty which meant
that the infections tended to be confined to them
for the most part amongst the younger population
so um we were now operating in a new world where
the case counts were going to be large and as I
said earlier um we were previously our models
were sort of previously designed to be sort of
more accurate at the lower case counts but when we
got to these larger case counts um maybe then the
differential equation kind of uh style modeling
is more appropriate still with uncertainty
quantification on the top so still with parameter
uncertainty that you have to think through that
that was the new style of modeling that we looked
at and one thing that was very interesting that
came out of that modeling was that testing is only
useful in that it reduces quarantine and isolation
uh if you do it enough if you don't do
it enough then you don't significantly
um cut these infections and there's also a
problem with that if you if you're testing at a
certain rate you are detecting cases by law we're
required to isolate those cases so there's a kind
of a there's a catch-22 here test enough you're
catching lots of potentially mild cases that you
would otherwise not worry too much about but that
when you catch those cases you have to quarantine
and isolate so even the asymptomatic cases right
that you wouldn't otherwise find testing may find
those so there was this very difficult question
of how much should we test if at all going forward
so one other critical thing was we we we found
that you know we had to predict like what would
happen um as the the spring semester progressed
a big issue is that when you think about those
case counts that you're seeing in the early
stages of some outbreak the people that
are most likely to be infected are the more
social individuals those with more contacts
so if you just look at those case counts that
you're seeing in those early days you're going
to overestimate what you're going to see in
case counts through the rest of the semester
and so that was something that we spend a fair
bit of time trying to uh to model and understand
so this modeling led to a new style of strategy
for the spring semester so basically we wanted
to avoid having to put people into isolation
all the time because it's really tough on them
for learning outcomes and mental health but
we also had to try to balance that with with
health so we did a few things we extended
our move-in period so that there would be
a sort of a more of a gentle ramp into the
semester we relaxed our regular PCR testing
um we had a few other accommodations that you
would have seen and used in in your place as well
so um uh these were all critical things that
came out of the modeling and the data analysis
that then again informed the university policy so
the key points that I want to highlight in what
I've shown you are asymptomatic screening super
powerful in controlling outbreaks and making
things safe if you can keep up uh we did reopen
we have been safe till now but we have had our
moments and the modeling and data analysis
was was core um we uh I showed you some of
the analysis but there was a lot of other stuff um
You probably have been involved in similar sort of
efforts in your local areas uh we all the code is
available you can find it um on this GitHub repo
so we also have a paper in proceedings
at the National Academy of Sciences
um but this is this experience has been
valuable in many ways and a big one is
how it's seated new research so I'm going to
finish on this slide so um we now know based
on looking back at this experience that we went
through what tools we wish we had access to in
the moment and so yes uh having a sort of a suite
of models that we can pull off the shelf and then
think carefully about the parameters for would
have been helpful that would have been great
um but really it was the parameter uncertainty
that was the The Big Driver of all of these
decisions and the modeling part was was it
was it was work but it wasn't the the core
so the uncertainty quantification how do you
represent your uncertainty about certain key
input parameters and there are many of them
right so you have to be thinking about uh the
sort of relationships between those parameters
um the second Point uh early infections are more
likely to be the more social individuals and
the issue that's going on here is if you just
count those count those cases then you're going
to overestimate what's going on in the general
population and if you're a bit puzzled by this
point think about something called the Friendship
Paradox which says if you look at how many if
you you know if you think about say Facebook
and you think about how many of your friends how
many friends do your friends have so you are an
individual look at uh the set of your friends
on Facebook count the average number of friends
they have and compare that to the average
number of friends you have it will be larger
the reason it's larger is that you're friends with
somebody who was an incredible socialite and that
person has an enormous number of friends and so
there's a sort of a systematic way that this this
biases things and so we had to try to reverse
reverse that effect and finally when you are
when you do have these limited interventions for
us that was testing but it could be vaccination
or many others how do you extend that to multiple
groups in such a way as to curtail growth rates
so we're working on all of these some of them
statistical some of them uh uh more optimization
based with a group of six of us that are
it's a mix of Public Health and operations
folks and a sociologists so I will stop there
thank you very much for the chance to be here
Shane thank you so much this was your experience
at Cornell was super interesting and I mean
obviously it's it seemed to have worked for you
and you were successful in kind of allowing people
to come back to campus and to to have in-person
classes which is you know I think is something
everybody wanted the going online it obviously
was was fraught it was sort of necessary but but
fraud and you guys came back and you were early
adopters of coming back to that I'm curious like
what other I'm sure you've interacted with other
universities um and other colleges around the
country both more in urban settings as well as in
more rural settings and did they see some of this
um these effects that were kind of predicted by
your model and can you say uh you know make some
changes to the parameterization of the model and
try and predict the experiences they might have
had if that makes sense yeah I know I understand
uh the point it's a it's a great Point um so yes
there were other universities that had similar
experiences so too that appeared in the news quite
a bit were Duke and UIUC so let me just highlight
UIUC I guess so again a campus that is in a
moderate sized town uh maybe there are quite a bit
bigger than Ithaca I think but um but nevertheless
a campus that sort of somehow removed from a large
urban center and they they had a similar strategy
and that similar strategy worked for them we did
not explicitly uh share our models with them in in
real time because they had their own modeling
group that was working on this as well but
certainly the since we've had time to sort of take
a deep breath after all of this kind of Madness
over the last couple of years we have been working
on cleaning up the code ensuring that that kind of
uncertainty quantification which was you know that
that I think was really the key in in everything
we were doing that is all available online and we
have not done what you've said which is to explore
their particular setting without you know sort of
adopt adapting the parameters for those settings
but certainly that would be something that would
be very doable in the work we're doing right now
we're thinking much more about a broader Community
like in a university community you can control
Behavior you can put into place these behavioral
compacts or at least at many universities not all
but what about a broader community so when you
get into the more rural areas around Ithaca you
certainly can't do that so what would be you
know what what are the overall Dynamics there
so that's the thing that we're focusing much
more on in in the present time yeah because I
think it's interesting that University and college
campuses are kind of an interesting petri dish for
like point of phrase here uh that's uh for this
type of a thing and you might imagine that you
know your experience in Cornell where you know
why I forget what you mentioned it's like 20
000 students uh is about the the size of the the
on you typical in Residence Community there in
Contra and you know you you're not necessarily
in a major urban center but you've got a college
town around you in contrast to something like if
you were at NYU for example so you're like in the
middle of a big metropolis and students are going
to be coming into contact with all sorts of other
non-students and non-academics they're going
to have just a different exposure probability
because they rode on a subway with somebody and
that's again in contrast to some other place like
Dartmouth which is up in rural New Hampshire which
got a really teeny town next to it but it's also
you know an Ivy League school but its experience
is going to be different than that Cornell
and you know University of Washington or Cal Poly
Pomona or you know some other school I'm just kind
of curious about just how that you know works out
because you're different you know you mentioned
all the the students who are more social maybe the
ones that are bringing the virus to to campus and
um you know if they're interacting with each
other as well as other people from outside the
university you know maybe that has a a factor a
bearing on some of the performance of the models
it it absolutely does so um we we were in close
contact with Ed Kaplan at Yale it is a a real
star in our community who's done just a tremendous
amount of different policy analysis work including
very early work on needle exchange programs
for HIV um all the way through so uh Yale um
as I'm sure you know is a is a sort of a moderate
sized campus but in a very Urban setting and so
it's a it's a very interesting uh case
in point that compares with with ours and
they were also trying to do regular asymptomatic
screening and uh but they had many more cases so
um I think it's exactly this point that you're
making that the the contacts with the local
community create a new source of infections which
uh we could we could you know to a large extent
avoid we still have a local community but nothing
like the size of uh New Haven in Connecticut
I it was touched by your comment about uh mbas and
St Patrick's Day don't go well with each other and
I was surprised in looking at some of your your
graphs that uh I didn't it didn't quite connect
with me but I didn't realize that Cornell was
such a party school but oftentimes the biggest
predictor of an outbreak was whether or not it
happened around you know times of Celebration
let's just say and that I'm curious what was
the University's request of the student body
in an attempt to kind of avoid those things I
mean you know it's college kids they're going
to do their fraternity parties that sort of thing
but did the University specifically ask them not
to do those things and they did them anyway or
what seemed to be the sociology there yeah it's
a very interesting um deal so so the university
did have a behavioral compact students had to
sign this compact to say that they were going
to be careful and isolate and do their best to
avoid multiple contacts per day and yes you still
have a modest minority who are going to engage in
riskier behavior for sure and so we kind of knew
that going and we just didn't know quite how much
of an impact that would have uh overall our
uh delightful surprise was that the Cornell
students as a whole were were not the Partiers
right they were they were mostly very very
responsible and so you know they really deserve
a tremendous amount of credit they knew that
um their in-person semester relied on them being
careful because if they weren't everyone was going
to have to be sent home and so this was something
that really uh I think motivated many of them but
we were still pleasantly surprised at how how
responsible they were nevertheless yeah you
still have those moments um you know everyone
needs to blow off some steam now and then and
I guess uh you know we had a little bit of bad
luck at times but but you know in some ways I
think that's inevitable and you need this kind of
that's why you need this sort of buttress against
uncertainty so when you do get those searches can
you get the search under control quickly yeah I I
can certainly understand and uh the the students
needed that opportunity to kind of you know
all that stress intention was uh was a lot for
everybody so I can't blame them at all um what are
some of the things moving forward what are some of
the opportunities that people interested in data
science and statistical modeling and uh predictive
modeling in particular um what are some of the
opportunities that may exist um you know now that
we're coming out of kind of that experience not
that it's gone away necessarily but we're kind of
emerging from it still um but what can we what can
we learn what can we move forward with what are
the opportunities that exist you know I I think
there's some very interesting things here I mean
obviously mathematical epidemiology is a very old
field with the tremendous depth and literature
which is just fantastic it's a huge resource for
us um but there I think one thing that has maybe
received a little bit less attention is this
interplay between the data and analysis and the
decision models that sort of feed on those that
data and and the parameters you can get from that
so there's a there's almost like there's a group
that does the data analysis and then there's a
separate group that does the decision modeling
and never never shall these two groups mixed
right and and I think that's that's where there's
there's huge uh opportunity and that's where we're
trying to focus our effort so we want to take into
account this data we want to analyze it in real
time but we also want to recognize the limitations
of that data when you're contact tracing and you
have a surge you can be overwhelmed and so that
leads to a sort of a a censoring of data and so
you have to think about that when you're when
you're fitting your parameters and if you ignore
it it's at your peril and all of that feeds into
decision models meanwhile there's a there's a flow
back as well like for a decision if the decision
um with a with a reasonable set of parameters is
very very clear it's miles away from a different
decision being optimal as we experienced with
coming back for an in-person semester that means
there's a lot of robustness to that decision and
uh you don't have to get your parameter estimates
very accurate to know that you're still safe with
that decision and so that means that you can spend
a little bit less effort um in in gathering
the the you know the sort of detailed data
on the ground for that so I I do think it's that
interplay which is the the growth area right now
Shane thank you so much for for sharing your
experience from Cornell I think this is uh
super interesting and uh I was like again very
interested to see the performance of your model
that it impacted the strategies that Cornell
undertook to come back a little earlier than
everybody else I'm very thankful that a lot of
those predictions seem to have borne out and it's
uh I know you must be very relieved but thank you
for sharing that experience with us and everybody
who's uh joining us or or watching online um thank
you so much we will not be having our seminar next
week in honor of uh the Thanksgiving holiday
here in the U.S but uh we look forward to uh
seeing everybody the following week um in early
December and uh once again Shane thank you so
much for sharing your experiences with us thank
you Jack and thanks everyone for coming along